Good Morning, John.
What is going on here?
This is a Dr. Pepper can.
And it's never been opened,
and it is doing this.
And it feels like it's super thin,
like it's a weird aluminum.
But it's only because aluminum cans are actually,
they're very fragile.
Except that they have high tensile strength so when they're being inflated
by the pressure inside of them,
they actually get quite strong.
When they're not, they're weak and floppy
but this has never leaked.
It's never been opened, but it's not got pressure in it.
So, let's open the normal one.
So, that sounded normal.
Now, let's open this. My guess is-
it's gonna sound different.
Yeah. This is a flat -
Dr. Pepper.
What's happening?
Normal Dr. Pepper, it tastes like regular Dr. Pepper.
And then this -
- barest tiniest tingle.
Authentic Blend of 23 Flavors!
But a - You missed one!
So I guess, the carbonation is necessary
to make a coke can feel like a coke can.
Otherwise, when it gets cold
all of the gas inside contracts
and then you get a weird deflated coke can.
I guess.
If anybody has any better theories than that,
let me know.
John, I've been thinking a lot about stories recently
Ah, because I've been working on my own, because I've just read yours,
and because it's the day after the 30th anniversary of Star Trek: The Next Generation.
The most formative piece of media in my life.
So, there's a guy who I never thought about
when I was a young person.
Didn't know he existed but
who had a tremendous impact on me.
Michael Piller was the showrunner for
Star Trek: The Next Generation.
From the third season to the end of the show.
The last couple years he shared that duty
with Jeri Taylor.
These people wrote a lot of episodes of Star Trek
but also managed the writing room.
Show running is a thing that back then,
in the 90s wasn't -
-  thought about by normal people, certainly not by me.
I was like eleven.
I was just watching an interview with Michael Piller today and he was -
- saying that, uh, they once went in with an idea
for a show and talked to Gene Roddenberry
the creator of Star Trek about (it).
And the episode was like an adventurous chase across the universe.
And Gene said, "What's it about?"
And they were like, "Well it's about an
adventurous chase across the universe."
But the thing about
Star Trek: The Next Generation,
the thing that I don't find too often these days in TV Sci-fi -
- is that it was always about something.
Like it was about the plot, but I feel like
if they were gonna sacrifice plot or meaning,
they were gonna sacrifice plot first.
It's so easy to write a story about good versus evil and spaceships blowing up,
it's hard to write a story about disability
or racism or what it means to be human
or like super cheesy stuff like
the value of honesty, right?
That's a hard thing to write about these days.
Like we're no longer The West Wing World,
we are The House of Cards World.
I'm a little- I'm a little bit sick of it and I think it's kind of boring.
I want to know what's it about.
And if you tell me it's about how messed up the world is and just evil people doing evil things-
I'm done!
I'm done with it. I don't want it anymore.
Give me stories that are about something. And something that I can be hopeful about.
Maybe? I mean -
It's hard. Right. Don't get me wrong.
When people ask me what's Turtles All The Way Down about, the first thing I think about isn't the plot.
Which is great. Like it's very interesting, like it kept me hooked throughout the whole book.
It's the themes. It's how do we maintain relationships with people who have problems with their brains?
How do we understand people who experience the world in fundamentally different ways than we do?
How is that a thing with people's brains just working differently but also in a world with such -
dramatic inequality as we have right now?
You know nothing about what happens in the book
from what I said but -
-  maybe you know what it's about.
Which is a thing I feel like we're not necessarily asking our self -
- in today's media enough. I think I learned from
Star Trek: The Next Generation
-which I hope you all will join me in watching a ton of this weekend on Netflix-
that themes are as important,
sometimes more important, than plots.
'Coz diversion is kind of the least of what a story can offer us.
We have to think about the stories that our world is built upon and that our selves are built upon,
which is, it turns out, a great way to create media whether it's video blogs or books or TV shows.
John, I'm really proud of you and your book.
I cannot wait for other people to read it.
And I'll see you on Tuesday.